also um during the pandemic um
have created new addictions yeah like
what
positive ones or negative ones probably
negative yes
video games that's not a new addiction
different genre though different genre
what are you into
well um normally
you're going to regret asking that
question i know i don't know all these
games
normally um i like um simulation games
usually
so like simulation of real life no like
um yes
like having a girlfriend or something no
no but like yes
he has multiple wives in these open
world games
yeah like in skyrim and he's really good
to them
he always chooses the storyline that
where he is a good husband oh that's so
sweet yeah tom and i are watching
uh love on the spectrum on netflix yes i
just started that
i love it yeah and there's this it's
about people with
autism dating and this one guy michael
is like if i had a wife
i would take the best care of her and
worship her and love her and i was like
tom
i kind of want to date an autistic guy
because they're so
into me if i could just have a fraction
of that enthusiasm
but there's also like it's so undiluted
they just say i mean we could be we
could afford to be a little bit more
like that we were just like just tell me
yeah just be straight up i love them
there's no
[ __ ] do you watch indian matchmaking
of course i've already seen it all i i
have
can i just go back to that yeah sorry
but spectrum spectrums
what are your dislikes i like when they
just dislikes and like
i like the sound of cats licking their
hands
what you just said about the guy going
well you know if i had a wife i would
yeah
but the thing is that women don't
want that deep down inside women want
mystery you know i mean they want a
little conflict they want to be hard to
get
i think it's a dated that's a dated
theory yeah
i'd like to be worshipped really you
want a guy
right when you wake up so fired up yeah
oh wait when you wake up
he's got like your breakfast in a tray
yes have you seen that show
on a lifetime television dirty hair
dirty
dirty john dirty we listen to the
podcast okay we listen to them we listen
to the whole thing yes yeah and every
morning
he he would bring her a smoothie and do
her you know errands
yeah but he would also dress up as a
doctor in scrubs
i know everywhere he went even to like
parties
minor drawback but the fact that he was
so devoted
okay if i'm dating a girl and i'm in bed
yeah
bring me breakfast i'm gonna wake me up
and you have breakfast
it's impossible just just wake me up
right now i'm sleeping
good morning oh god what time is it what
time is it
it's 3 p.m oh [ __ ] what what's up what's
up
here i made you breakfast oh um we don't
have a [ __ ] kitchen
we don't have a dining room why in the
bed i sleep here [ __ ]
wow pretty accurate is that what he does
yeah he
he's like a cat you he only does
affection if
on his time and on his approach oh i
hate that
you love it i'm a dog yeah see that's
why you and i get along
love me pat me play with me let's go
let's go let's my hair yeah yeah
i disappear for eight hours how do you
and tom do it
sorry i'm glad you pretend what i don't
know who you are
all right let's move on how you and tom
do it do what no i mean like do you
are you co-mingling throughout the day
or do you just
do your own thing and then wind down
together at the end of the day
um i i we both do it kind of do our own
thing like i have a i do
i wake up let's say today i did i took a
tennis lesson and while i was doing that
he did a podcast